(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
♪ Strange light revolves around you ♪
♪ You float across the room ♪
♪ Your touch is made of something ♪
♪ Heaven can't hold a candle too ♪
♪ You're made of somethin' new ♪
♪ Let's not get complicated ♪
♪ Let's just enjoy the view ♪
♪ It's hard to be a human ♪
♪ So much to put an answer to ♪
♪ But that's just what we do ♪
♪ God only knows where this could go ♪
♪ And even if our love starts
to grow outta control ♪
♪ And you and me go up in flames ♪
♪ Heaven won't be the same ♪
♪ I believe, I believe, I
could die in your kiss ♪
♪ No, it doesn't get, doesn't
get better than this ♪
♪ God only knows where this could go ♪
♪ And even if our love starts
to grow outta control ♪
♪ And you and me go up in flames ♪
♪ Heaven won't be the same ♪
♪ God only knows where this could go ♪
♪ And even if our love starts
to grow outta control ♪
♪ And you and me go up in flames ♪
♪ Heaven won't be the same ♪
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Oh, thank you.
Welcome.
(audience cheering)
Welcome to "The Kelly
Clarkson Show," everybody.
(audience applauding)
Give it up for my crazy,
great band, y'all.
(audience cheering)
So I love that song, I've
listened to that song so much,
that was "Heaven," by
my friend, Niall Horan.
It was released last year,
I believe, but he showed us,
we we're still working on "The Voice,"
and he showed us this song,
like, just a tiny snippet,
like, I mean, seconds, and I
was like, "No, wait, what?"
And I loved it so much,
and it stayed in my head.
I just think it's my favorite song,
he's such a great songwriter,
but it's my favorite song he's released.
I love it so much, you should
go check out his album.
Anyway-